this episode of real science is brought
to you by curiosity stream
sign up today at curiositystream.com
real science
and get free access to watchnebula.com
[Music]
it's the one thing everyone can agree on
mosquitoes are the worst
for some they are simply the ruiner of
picnics and camping trips
but for a huge fraction of the world
they are much more than a nuisance
mosquitoes cause more human suffering
than any other organism
because of the horrific diseases they
carry over a million people worldwide
die from mosquito-borne diseases every
year
in a previous video i talked about
malaria perhaps the most devastating of
all the mosquito-borne illnesses
killing about half a million people each
year and while less common
other diseases like west nile virus
yellow fever and dengue fever
are each insidious in their own way
debilitating and deadly to many in the
tropics and subtropics
some diseases like malaria are declining
but other diseases like dengue are very
much on the rise
in the past 30 years the worldwide
incidence of dengue has risen 30-fold
billions get spent trying to combat
these diseases
vaccines insecticides education programs
bed nets treatment drugs prevention
drugs
there are so many things scientists do
to try to stem the tide of infections
but even as progress is made in one
region infections will flare up in
others
it's like the worst game of whack-a-mole
imaginable
it takes an unprecedented coordinated
effort across
many geographic and political lines to
even make a dent
and an insane amount of money but much
of the current funding has plateaued
and some of the drugs that have been
used for years are becoming less and
less effective
the malaria parasite in particular has
started to develop resistance to
currently available drugs
insecticide resistance is also becoming
a challenge in many mosquito species
including the widespread and usually
invasive aedes egypti
and this is why some scientists are
looking towards a totally new approach
something radical
and controversial to end the
whack-a-mole game once and for all
genetically modified mosquitoes in
theory
their widespread release could lead to
the total extinction of certain species
of mosquitoes
eliminating the vector for so many
deadly diseases
it's an extreme idea but a future with
gm mosquitoes flying freely in our world
may not be that far away this summer
genetically modified 80s egyptian
mosquitoes could be released in the u.s
for the first time
in florida and in texas so is this a
sudden jurassic park experiment
or the logical next step in controlling
mosquito-borne illness
in may of this year the epa in the state
of florida unanimously approved an
experimental use permit
for millions of gm mosquitoes to be
released in the florida keys for a
landmark project
the mosquitoes are genetically modified
male 80s egypti mosquitoes
known as ox-5034 branded as friendly
tm mosquitoes developed by the company
oxitec
aedes aegypti are an invasive species in
most places they exist
originally from africa they have spread
worldwide to almost every tropical and
subtropical area
they are often described as the
cockroach of mosquitoes
they thrive specifically living around
people and are hard to get rid of
they lay their eggs in any container
they can find like inside of a clogged
gutter
a toilet tank a flower pot or discarded
bottles or bottle caps
making it hard to get a handle on their
spread they can bite
multiple people during their lifespan
creating a huge potential to spread
viruses
and unluckily for humans they carry so
many horrible ones
zika the microcephaly causing virus and
dengue often called break bone fever for
how painful it is
are some of the worst ones they carry
and this is why the adc gypti mosquito
has been targeted as a candidate for the
gm technology
at the heart of the so-called friendly
mosquito is something called a
self-limiting gene
it starts with 80s egyptian mosquito
eggs which are injected with short
pieces of dna
that contain the self-limiting gene
sequence along with a fluorescence gene
that acts as a marker
this lethal gene is a tetracycline
transcriptional activator variant
or ttav gene once introduced into the
mosquito's genome
it encodes a protein that blocks
transcriptional machinery
for several other genes that are
essential to mosquito development
so without essential genes being
expressed the mosquito larvae die before
becoming adults
but simply injecting the t-tav gene into
these eggs would only be useful in
killing the handful of mosquitoes you
give it to
hardly an economical way to kill off the
trillions of mosquitoes that exist in
the world
for the gene technology to be useful the
mosquitoes need to be able to pass the
lethal gene down to their offspring
and for this reason the lethal gene has
a corresponding antidote
to keep the mosquito larvae with this
lethal gene alive
they can be given tetracycline a common
antibiotic
the lethal t-tav protein cannot block
the transcription of the other essential
mosquito genes when it's bound to
tetracycline
this can therefore keep the gm larvae
alive until adulthood
when the gene is no longer lethal so in
the lab mosquito eggs are injected with
the self-limiting gene
and the gm mosquito larvae are then
reared in water containing tetracycline
this way they can develop normally into
adult mosquitoes
then when adult gm mosquitoes are
released and breed with
wild non-gm mosquitoes their offspring
inherit the lethal t-tav gene
and without tetracycline in their
environment they don't survive into
adulthood
over time and with enough gm mosquitoes
released this technology has the ability
to hugely suppress the numbers of
mosquitoes in the wild
and to make the technology even more
powerful scientists recently found a way
to ensure that the lethal gene
only kills the female offspring because
of this
one copy of the t-tav gene remains in
some of the male offspring of the
injected mosquitoes
who can then pass it on to some of their
offspring this allows the gene to kill
more mosquitoes across
multiple generations until it eventually
disappears from the gene pool
after about 10 generations
if effective this friendly mosquito
technology could almost completely
protect communities from dengue
yellow fever zika and other
mosquito-borne illnesses carried by the
adc gypti mosquito
without needing insecticides and the
hope is that soon
this same technology could be applied to
any of the most damaging mosquito
species
including the anopheles mosquito that
carries malaria
the newest iteration of the technology
is what is slated to possibly be tested
in florida at the end of the summer
in texas soon after that but if these
trials go ahead
they will not be the first time gm
mosquitoes have been tested in the wild
previous generations of the technology
have already been tested
with field trials taking place in panama
the cayman islands
malaysia and perhaps most significantly
brazil
[Music]
the field trials in brazil began in 2011
with the first generation of the
friendly mosquito technology
ox-513a the studies were conducted in
the semi-arid northeast of brazil
in suburbs with a huge amount of dengue
adc gypdy thrived there
due to the amount of stored water and a
high human population
and thus provided the perfect place to
test the technology
male mosquitoes with the lethal gene
insertion were dispersed in the study
area by opening release devices through
the window of a moving car
these mosquitoes then went on to mate
with the local population of females
and their offspring having inherited the
ttav gene
could not survive oxitec reports that in
this study
the local 80s egypti population was
reduced by 80 to 95 percent
after a year of consistent releases some
critics of the study
claim that the suppression of mosquitoes
was more like 60 to 70
but even still that is far better than
traditional methods like insecticide
spraying
which rarely achieve much more than 50
suppression
since then oxitec has also tested their
second generation of friendly mosquitoes
ox-5034 in brazil and achieved a similar
result
with reports of up to 98 suppression in
just a 13-week window
and this is the same technology that has
been granted an experimental use permit
for field trials in florida and texas
these places don't currently have
devastating mosquito-borne disease
outbreaks like many places in the
tropics
but dengue and zika have both worryingly
popped up in these places in recent
years
health officials are trying to keep
these diseases at bay
and their occurrence is an ever-present
possibility
and while the results from the field
trials so far have been promising
the question on everyone's mind is is it
safe
experiments with gm mosquitoes are often
compared to jurassic park
implying that these experiments could
lead to drastic out of control
and dire outcomes that releasing these
mosquitoes could open an
unforeseen pandora's box that we cannot
close again
and while yes it is impossible to
foresee every outcome
the technology can be assessed with what
we know about it and what we know about
genetics in general
the main risk that opponents of this
technology want to avoid
is the potential for harm to humans an
important and valid concern
critics claim that there is a risk that
the genes from the gm mosquito could be
transferred to humans or other animals
that have been bitten
but a gm mosquito biting a human is
unlikely to begin with
because only the females bite and the
females are engineered
to die but in the unlikely event that
some females do survive
and do bite people the transfer of
genetic material from mosquito to human
just doesn't happen
gmo or not mosquitoes have been feeding
on humans for more than a hundred
million years
by assessing the genomes of humans and
many mosquito species
we can see that there is no evidence of
gene transfer via blood feeding
even if this hypothetically were to
occur even at extremely low frequencies
we would be able to see dna sequences
from human feeding mosquitoes in humans
and from bird feeding mosquitoes and
birds and so on
and the reverse is also true even if
animals consume the gm mosquitoes
animals do not incorporate dna from
their food into their genome
gmo or not numerous studies have shown
that livestock or chickens that eat gm
corn for example
do not have any trace of the genetic
material in their bodies after eating it
horizontal gene transfer like this is a
commonly cited worry
and it should definitely continue to be
studied rigorously
but with all the information we have so
far it seems like this scenario is
extremely unlikely
other risks that critics cite are the
potential impacts on the environment
the first that comes to mind for many
people is if we kill off the mosquitoes
will this harm the food chain will it
leave the birds
frogs and other animals with less to eat
this would certainly be a major concern
if we were to eradicate all species of
mosquitoes across the globe
for reference there are 3 500 different
species of mosquitoes around the world
and 80 species that occur in florida and
85 in texas
but the studies being proposed in
florida and texas only focus on one
species
the adc gypti which is also an invasive
species in both places
and because it's non-native to the area
it has not co-evolved with other
organisms in the ecosystem
and is not a keystone species that other
animals need for food
one day if we do want to kill off all of
the disease-carrying mosquitoes
this question will need to be studied
more carefully but even still
of the 112 genera of mosquitoes just
three
bear the primary responsibility for the
spread of human diseases
there are so many factors that go into
trying to assess the risks of a new
technology like this
and i can't begin to address them all
here
if you want to read more about the risk
assessments done there is a 140-page
document addressing many of the concerns
put forth by the public
concerning auxitex gm mosquitoes which i
will link below
oxitec has gone through a lot of
rigorous testing to try to make sure
their technology is safe
but you can never be a hundred percent
sure that it's foolproof
and this is where all the debate comes
in a previously planned release in the
florida keys of an earlier version of
oxitec's gm mosquito was withdrawn
after a referendum indicated significant
opposition from local residents
and more recently the public forum on
oxitec's recent permit application
garnered 31 000 comments opposing
release
and 56 in support and before the study
can go ahead
it needs final approval by the mosquito
control district
and it is not a sure thing that that
will happen
many people do oppose testing this
technology without understanding the
first thing about it
but some of the concerns with the bias
of oxitec's risk assessment are valid
yes the research oxitec is doing needs
to be transparent
with lots of independent research done
to remove any bias
but ultimately a new technology to fight
mosquito-borne illness is desperately
needed
and this looks like it could one day
provide the solution that the million
dead people per year
probably wished they had
our modern world is increasingly being
shaped by our understanding of genetics
with major breakthroughs in gmos and
gene editing in recent years
in the next video i will talk about
crispr and how it is already reshaping
how we think about disease
genetic advances like this are extremely
complex
and inherently come with a lot of
uncertainty and therefore a lot of
controversy
but genetic engineering is going to be
in our futures
if you want to learn more about genetics
then you should sign up for curiosity
stream
curiosity stream is a streaming platform
that has thousands of high quality high
budget documentaries
like this one called dynamic genomes
which explores how the junk part of our
dna
may actually work to decide our personal
characteristics and tendencies
it's a great overview of how mysterious
and complicated our genetics really are
but doesn't skimp on the science and if
you're a fan of educational content
and have accepted your fate that this
lockdown will never be over then this is
the perfect time to sign up
because a subscription to curiosity
stream now also comes with a
subscription to nebula
nebula is a place where top educational
content creators
like polyphonic wendover productions and
our other channel real engineering
can create videos freely without
worrying about the youtube algorithm or
demonetization
it's a place where we can upload our
content ad-free
and also experiment with original
content and new series
the original content is the best part of
nebula with shows like real
engineering's logistics of d-day series
the latest episode is about the
logistics of air support
which required new airfields to be
constructed rapidly within
spitting distance of the front line so
if you sign up for curiositystream at
curiositystream.com
real science you'll get a subscription
to curiosity stream and a subscription
to nebula
for just 14.79 for the whole year
by signing up you're not just supporting
this channel but all of your favorite
educational content creators
thanks for watching and if you would
like to see more from me the links to my
instagram
twitter and patreon are below
you